the media landscape is changing press is
able to work whatever they wanted
challenges from social media to merely
that was all distorted the rise of fake
news that was alternative information -
laughs an attempt to distort reality
zhing serious questions about the
media's future long gone are the days
when people just picked up a newspaper
or tuned in to the 6 o'clock news 24
hour channels digital platforms and
social media broke the mold and now
we're increasingly watching news in
different ways and on different devices
Martha Lane Fox who sits on the board of
Twitter and campaigns for Responsible
tech says social media and traditional
media and now so interlinked both need
to address trust issues
some of the challenges around some of
the misinformation particularly and what
people would call fake news on social
media platforms is often the traditional
media amplifying those messages I think
we have to accept that this has become a
bit complicit and there's a two-way
equation going on there the companies
themselves the tech platforms need to
make sure they continue to give high
quality of information on their
platforms the media has to come to terms
not just with the transformation of the
industry but also with concerns about
its own conduct Paul - was caught up in
the 7/7 bombings and the subsequent
media storm
I found that experience more daunting
than being involved in the terrorist
attack the day before those in the media
have a duty of care to people like
myself I I was on my own there wasn't
really a concern for my welfare
bear in mind what I've been involved in
the day before in the last year there's
been a huge surge in engagement with the
news in a 2018 survey 50% of people said
they consumed news weekly or more this
year it jumped to 72 percent but 73% of
people are still worried about fake news
being used as a weapon and media
organizations know they need loyal
audiences to survive you're seeing a lot
more fact checking and instant rebuttals
happening
and work being done to talk about the
type of sourcing and what and where
information comes from quoting the right
sorts of experts and Sky News is making
transparency a priority on its 30th
anniversary installing over 30 cameras
in the newsroom in a bid to demystify
how news is really made Luci Casa Sky
News